hi everyone I'm Alexandra I work at ello
dot at where we're building a product
that acts as a manager's copilot so
sometimes it helps you organize your
one-on-ones collect feedback take notes
and team meetings and track action items
so that sounds like something that would
be interesting to you come talk to me
after or check out fellow dot app but
today I want to talk to you about
something completely different which is
a project I've been working on in my
spare time and this is an app that I
built for my phone that lets you access
the Internet in a real browser without
actually having to have a data or Wi-Fi
connection that transfers everything
over SMS so to give you a preview of
what this is going to look like on the
Left we have a screenshot of the app
where you're gonna enter the URL for the
website that you want to visit and on
the right side there's a screenshot from
my default messaging application which
shows the communication that goes on
behind the scenes between the phone and
the server so why on earth would I make
something like this when we already have
access to free Wi-Fi and data
connections all over the world I come
from a country where I get two gigabytes
two gigabytes of data every month for
$80 and the prices for internet are so
expensive in this country that
three-quarters of a million people are
still using dial-up internet connections
in their home I come from Canada
so the data prices are so expensive just
when I'm at home in my own country it's
whenever I'm traveling I have to pay an
arm and a leg just to be able to browse
the internet like to be here right now
I'm paying $100 just to get access to
one gigabyte of data and this is kind of
an issue for me because I really really
love to travel and I spend a lot of time
in places like Paris where the streets
look like this they're kind of all over
the place and I am extremely
directionally impaired so I get lost in
New York City where the streets are in a
grid and numbered and I end up in these
situations when I visit places like
Paris where I walk an hour in one
direction and I'll have to figure out
how to take the subway to get back to
where I was originally trying to go so I
could technically download an offline
map and use that to figure out how to
walk around but when I want to take the
subway that's the kind of thing that
requires up-to-date real-time
information and you can't get that
online and so I decided to do something
about this and one of the first things
that I noticed when I started trying to
solve this problem is that my phone my
phone plan has unlimited a snap SMS in
most countries or a very very cheap
messaging so originally a couple years
ago when I started this the big thing at
the time was building chat BOTS and a
lot of companies started building these
interfaces through like facebook
Messenger or whatever so I decided that
because I have unlimited SMS I'll build
a chat bot and the way that it worked
was I would be able to send a message
like how do I get from here to there
that message would be sent to my server
my server would have unlimited access to
the internet so it would use the Google
Maps API to get those directions and
text them back to me so I could do this
in France for about 15 cents and I would
get all the directions that I needed
real time and I use this a lot and it
had a lot of things like being able to
store address books so I could just say
how do I get home it would you could say
I want to get there at 4:00 p.m. it
would do that for you but it was so
useful that I kind of got addicted to
having access to the Internet so I would
want to look up a translation of a word
and I built an API integration for that
or I want to look up the rating for a
restaurant I was next
- and it would build an API integration
for that and I started spending so much
time building all these one-off
integrations I decided this is kind of
silly I shouldn't be doing this
I should just build a browser instead
and that is what we're gonna go over now
there are two parts to this project so
there's the Android app on one side and
the node.js server on the other the app
I built in Android because I figured
this is something I'm gonna use so screw
iPhones I did it in Java and not Kotlin
because I was completely new to building
phone apps I had never worked with yes -
API and I figured there's a lot more on
Stack Overflow about SMS with Java so
I'm gonna go with that because of the
community around it the server I built
in node.js because I thought it would be
really funny to put JavaScript on the
server where it does not belong to
create a browser without JavaScript
where it's supposed to be for the
communication between these two these
two parts I use Twilio so Thalia was a
really great company that has a lot of
different services all around
communication and messaging the part
that I used here is something that lets
me forward SMS to a server so what I've
done is I bought a number on Twilio and
every phone or every message that I send
to that phone number will be sent as a
post request with a bunch of information
about the message to my server to set up
the limitations that I had to deal with
for this project so I want to transfer
an entire webpage over SMS to my phone
but SMS only allows for a hundred and
sixty characters at a time which is
about the size of a tweet so it kinda is
discouraging already to have to transfer
a whole bunch of messages this way and
even more so if you look at a page
that's very simple like Google although
we always think about when we look at
this page is the input and the button
and maybe the word Google but when you
actually look at the source of this page
this is a quarter million characters in
HTML so if we were to break this up into
messages and
without doing anything to it it would
take 1300 SMS to get there and this will
cost me $10 in Twilio fees alone which
is a lot more than I was willing to pay
but when we think about what that web
page looks like and the functionality
behind it we really only think of it as
being the form the word that input the
button and it's very very small and fits
into a single SMS and so when I was
going about this I decided that any
webpage I have I'm gonna want to make a
programmatic way to get it down from
this big bulky thing to a tiny thing
that just represents the interactions
that I want to have with it so we're
going to walk through the life cycle of
requesting a website and then actually
getting around to rendering it right off
the bat when we want to request a URL we
end up with a pretty big limitation URLs
the spec says that a URL can be 2,000
characters in length which could end up
taking thirteen whole SMS so when we
start off by requesting a URL the first
thing we're gonna do is take it and chop
off the HTTP www-wait a cup space and
the message the browser that I built
also isn't going to support any kind of
tracking information or like fancy
JavaScript stuff so anything that falls
after the real part of the URL is
something we can just get rid of so if
we have a URL like this we can just use
the yellow part that's highlighted and
send that over SMS
and to do that Android has this very
very simple SMS manager API which is
just lines 9 and 10 here this took many
hours of stock overflowing to figure out
it was very difficult but really all you
have to do is get permissions to send
receive and read SMS and then initialize
yes mess manager API specify the phone
number you want to send the message to
specify the body is a message and then
it sends it off for you and takes care
of everything so then this message is
sent to the Twilio number that I own and
Twilio takes that and turns it into this
very very big JSON blob with a whole
bunch of information and I've
highlighted that parts that are really
important here so at first we have the
body which is just the URL that we're
requesting the to number which is the
number that I have and the from number
which is the number that we're going to
want to send the data back to at the end
so this is sent to the server which then
has to do a lot of processing so I spend
a lot of time working on react
components which when you look at them
on their own are very very small tiny
things and I kind of forgot sometimes
just how big our website's end up being
so I accidentally press view page source
pretty often when I mean inspect element
and I see this wall of HTML that looks
horrible and it's impossible to
understand looking at like this and this
is the HTML that the server has to deal
with when it's trying to figure out how
to send this over SMS but there are a
lot of things in this HTML that we know
we can get rid of right off the bat like
we aren't going to support JavaScript so
we can get rid of all of that code we're
not going to support CSS so we can get
rid of all style tags we're not going to
support things like images so the first
thing that happens to get that HTML is
on the node.js server we're using
Express to set up this web application
so we're gonna start by grabbing that
URL from the text message prepending
HTTP so it's a real URL just getting the
HTML for the
Paige and then loading it into a library
called cheerio and cheerio is like
jQuery for the server and all are going
to use that for is to get the body of
that page so that we already have a much
smaller subset of code to deal with the
next thing that we're going to do is use
this library called sanitize HTML and
this is a library that lets you
determine what tags you want and what
attributes on those tags you want and
then you pass it some HTML and it will
filter that down to just what you want
it to be so I figured that in this very
simple browser
the only tags that I really care about
other than text are anchor tags input
elements and forms because those are the
things that let you access the rest of
the internet and really interact with a
text-based website and then on those
tags sue only attributes really care
about are things like the value the type
the name so anything that's class or
data like we can get rid of because we
don't have a CSS so allowing class tags
with our class attributes would take up
quite a bit of space that we don't
really have the ability to use the last
part of sanitize HTML here is this
exclusive filter and that's something
that lets you set up a function of the
tags and attributes so for example we
might want to hide all hidden inputs
because we're not going to be able to
see them so it's kind of wasted space
and then also we want to get rid of
privacy policies and terms and
conditions because we're not gonna click
on them so there's no point setting them
at this point we have a lot like a lot
of text and a couple of different HTML
tags here and there and so we have to
start compressing the English text and
the logical thing to do at this point is
to run this through gzip and sendai but
this is not a logical problem
so the first way that I decided to
compress the text is by doing character
replacements for really con words so the
word the and are extremely common in
English and there are a lot of letters
in English that aren't used like
everything except for a and I and so
what I decide to do is replace these
common words with the single letter
variations so da becomes T and becomes
ampersand and like so on and so forth
and this is a really easy compression to
decompress on the android side because
we know that if we see a single letter
on its own that is not a RI it's clearly
supposed to be that other word so we can
do this for the 24 letters that don't
mean anything and then we can start
doing the combinations of two letters
that don't mean anything and we can
compress a lot of words in the end this
way to do that all we have to do is set
up this mapping of long word to short
word and then just go through that
mapping and do a replace all we don't
care about the structure of the HTML at
this point it's probably going to be
okay if you're visiting a website like
Wikipedia there are probably a lot of
really big words that don't need to be
that big so penitentiaries is a 12
letter word that in most contacts is
going to mean the same thing as jail
which is a four letter word so we can
use a thesaurus API to find these long
words find synonyms for them that are
really short and replace those this is
not a reversible compression
it's so on the Android side you you
could take all the very short words and
find the longest possible synonyms for
them but it's you're gonna get some
interesting results the next way that
we're gonna start compressing things is
by replacing links so when I'm on my
computer I have the proper behavior of
hovering over a link before I click it
seeing that it's a good trustworthy link
and then and clicking on it when I'm on
my phone I just clink on the link and I
don't care where it goes and I decided I
should take advantage of that behavior
so what I do here is let's say I have a
link in real HTML that goes to a fellow
dot up what I can do is replace that
link with a three character long random
string send that over to the browser or
to the app and then when I click on the
app that three long three length care of
that thing is sent back to the server
and then the server knows oh this isn't
a real URL I should figure out what it's
supposed to be and then get the HTML for
that correct link and that saves a lot
of space on a lot of websites because
web sites are covered with links and
sometimes the words that are linked are
really really short but the URLs tend to
be extremely long so this saves a lot of
space and the way that I do this is by
using Redis which is a in-memory key
value data store so for every URL that's
encountered in the HTML it's passed to
this URL shortener function and it
generates the random string and then it
sets the value in Redis as the phone
number underscore short URL that's sorry
that's the key and then the value is the
real URL and this so setting it with the
phone number first reduces the chances
of there being collisions but there
there still is the chance that you'll
get the same you are all stored under
the same the same short link but that's
okay it's our it's all going to be our
own URL so it's not a big deal
okay so the last way of compressing the
HTML is by using Greek characters one of
the great things about the asanas
character side is that it allows for
Greek characters and most of the
websites that I visit at least do not
have Greek characters on them and so I
decide to take advantage of that now
because we have such a small subset of
HTML tags and attributes I figured
there's this way of mapping all of these
combinations to different characters
so I've color-coded the the original
version and the shortened version here
so like the bracket input is that first
one type equals quotation mark is the
second one and it might look a bit odd
that the words are combined with
different like equals in quotation marks
but we know that type is always going to
be followed by an equals and then a
quotation mark and so we can do this
because we have enough characters in in
the Greek letters to do this explicit
mapping and this shortens it quite a bit
one of the issues with SMS is that it
does not have guaranteed delivery or
guarantee that it will arrive in the
same order that it's sent so we might
end up with this situation where we have
six messages sent two of them never make
it and then the floor that do arrive
completely out of order I decided to
ignore the fact that some SMS might not
make it in order to recover from that
kind of issue would require building out
an entire networking system and that was
a bit above what I wanted to do with
this because if some of the messages
don't arrive you can just reload the
page and it's not going to be a huge
issue but for the arriving out of order
issue that's quite a big thing with my
phone so what I've done here is if if
these three messages make up the
entirety of the HTML to be sent out
we're going to prefix them with some
metadata that specifies the number of
messages that are in this page and then
the index that they fall under so we
know after getting the first message we
have to wait for a total of three and
then once a three arrived we know what
order to place them in so that we get
actual valid HTML at the end
and to do this Tulio has a great nodejs
library so all we have to do is say
messages dot create and then specify the
body of the message who the message is
from and then the the number that it's
going to which is something that was
sent in the poster post earlier on so
now this is being sent back to the phone
and the way we receive a is through
something on Android called a broadcast
receiver and a broadcast receiver is
something that you can set up to listen
out for different signals for events
that happen within the phone so here I
have them set up to listen out for
incoming SMS and what this does is it
just waits for all the SMS not shown
here very condensed but waits for all
the SMS and then sends it off to an
activity which is androids version of
view so once we have all the SMS and
we've concatenated them together we have
to start by reversing the Greek letter
conversion so that we have some real
HTML to deal with reverse the shortened
English words so not the thesaurus way
just the like single letter shortening
we're gonna add some spaces between the
closing and opening tags just to add a
little bit of visual interest to the
page because there's no CSS there's
nothing so we got to make it a little
bit more readable and then we're gonna
load it in a webview so if you've ever
opened slack and clicked on a link and
it opens chrome within slack they're
using a webview component so a webview
is chrome within an app and you can
either send it a URL to open or
amazingly you can send it some HTML to
open which was the best discovery in the
world because when I was building this I
thought for the longest time that I was
gonna have to build my own rendering
engine and I almost stopped
and this is what it looks like so on the
right side we have the actual message
that was sent to transfer all of
google.ca and on the Left we have the
rendering in the app of that web page so
this this is pretty on point with what
Google looked like 15 years ago so it's
not too bad when I started this out I
saw a goal of getting this webpage down
to 10 SMS and I thought that would be a
completely unattainable amazing thing to
do because it started off being 1,300
and I got it down to 3 SMS for this
whole page so so once I did that I was
really interested because this project
is named dial-up
I was curious to see how fast is this
compared to actual dialogue on my phone
on a good day using a regular browser it
takes 2 seconds to load this page on
dial-up a couple years ago overtaking 45
seconds to a minute or so and using this
method over SMS it takes 10 seconds
which when you have one it's the only
way you have of accessing the Internet
that's not long at all SMS is not secure
at all
SMS has the capability of being
intercepted it's not encrypted it's yeah
it's not secure so this is not something
that should be used for anything
password related anything credit card
related anything like that so one of the
things that I do is get rid of sign-in
links because if we're not going to
click on them anyway why see or why use
the space but on the other hand because
this browser does not have any tracking
or any cookies or anything like that
this is more secure than a lot of
browsers one of the ways that this
project could have been in quite a bit
easier is using MMS instead of SMS and
so that only costs a fraction of a cent
more and it supports quite a bit more
data but just like gzip that is just not
a fun solution there are a lot of things
that can be done with this project so
one of the we can do things like web
sockets because phones and SMS are by
nature bi-directional communication so
the server could just send a text
message to the phone whenever there's a
new notification there's nothing fancy
we set up there we could do things like
Ajax so if I visit Twitter a lot I could
store the HTML and the CSS required for
that webpage on my phone ahead of time
and then use the these requests to only
get the contents of tweets or the
content that really changes we could
also add support for JavaScript or my
favorite one is support for real dial-up
so through the Android API you can also
make voice calls and I thought would be
really cool if instead of doing SMS if
it did real dial-up where you initiate a
phone call the server and phone like go
back and forth for a couple seconds and
then all the data for a website is
transferred that way it would probably
only take a couple seconds and might end
up being cheaper and more reliable than
SMS so that would just be super cool
going backwards
so I did not know about travel sim cards
when I started this project I I found
out about these a few months ago if you
don't know you can get a travel SIM card
for about 20 or 30 dollars and it gives
that you access to about 20 gigabytes of
data in whatever country you're
traveling to in comparison I pay $80 for
two gigs so this is this is a great
solution and this is what I do now you
want to get in touch with me or check
out more about the project here's my
website and Twitter thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]